المستخدم والفيديو للمقهى Arina goncharova
لقطات من الدف يهين الخنزير سهم أماه لام
ياشا سودات
olya إلى tamara tsanava الخاص بالطفل الذي أنت عليه
ضغينة المذنب أكيتا على الملكة
صيد امرأة فقط على منصة الشتاء
دورة Goncharov قطاع الطرق Jedi بحيرة و
أعطِ الجو قيلولة للعالم ، نحن خلفك بيديك
الأثينيين من نفس مع الدليل على ذلك
قادرة على تصميم مجال ميداليات كاترينا و
مجفف الشعر مع uli إلزامي فول الصويا u لا يزال نعم
أرقام سليم تعطي بالياكين
فلاش الأشرار مانات مبيض أو الشتاء
salate ttp للضوء سأقتله
تزوير على جبهات نواتج دونباس
ندرة نرحب طوعا
لم يكن هناك فحص
أتى لو ولد شخص ب 3 وهم
وقفت في الممر ، وأذكر أنك الشيء الرئيسي هنا
تاتيانا فيكتوروفنا
والباقي منكم امراة لست انا و
خرجت إلى الموضوع الذي استعد
انتظر انا قادم الان
مواهبهم الباسلة وكما هي عليه
انتهى كل شيء كان هناك مال
ومستحضرات التجميل للعطور
أعطى الذبابة تغرق بعيدا اللعنة قبالة إيرينا ليخا lotar
حلقات من تشكيل ملحة بالكاد على alpha ru
أكثر أرجين يجب أن تذهب في نزهة على الأقدام وفيلم
كنت هناك وكانت تسقي وعقلها
المال أولا وتجول
مبالغ ضخمة ضخمة جدا لعبت
في لعبة ، أي بحتة في المجتمع
زجاجة لعبة شبكة لعبت
استثمر أموال مجنون بغباء
كان هناك آلاف عشرة آلاف سطر
حسنا في البداية
شمبانيا ثم كونياك ثم بييسك
وهناك وهذا القمر ، أي كل هذا
أكل أقول أن الرجل يستيقظ في حالة سكر
ذهب للعب مرة أخرى بدأ في النوم
شربوا هناك مرة أخرى ، نعم ، إذا لزم الأمر ، في مكان ما
الأعمال فضت
ذهب في العمل وجاء مرة أخرى الأطفال
لا تطعم الجدول قائلة أنه لا يوجد شيء هناك
مرة أخرى كان لا بد من عدم القيام بذلك
وذمة العام إيرينا جونشاروفا الدبابير عندما
كمكتب خلفي في عرض واحد 1
يوليو
ثم ببطء الخدين ربما
كن أي شيء
الصفحة الرئيسية
مزيد من الألم ، انظر
كانت هناك مواقف بالنسبة له ليقولها أيضًا
خائفة جدا من لقاءك مع زوجك
غادرت مع ابنتي ، جاءت وأخذت
ابنتي و
لم أعطي أنا أيضا مع الشرطة
حاولت حل هذه المشكلة ، فلماذا أفعل
قيل لهذه الجدة أن تجد أكثر
طفل في مثل هذه الشقة
جسديا لا يمكن لأن الثابت
مرات التدخين وشرب الكحول والضرب
الأطفال ليس لإثبات كل ذلك نحن
جاء إلى هذه المرأة المجيدة كانت
لديها حوالي شهرين و
وفي نفس الوقت صورت كل ما يحدث
في هذه الشقة
مخيف حتى أوليا كينتا برانتلي للثلج
وعلى مثل هذا الصلب الخامس والثمار ليست كذلك
Jedi أنا أعرض الجميع بالفعل
interdistrict 7 مكتب المدعي العام الروسي
تم اتخاذ قرار بالرفض
بدء دعوى جنائية
القسم الرئيسي للوزارة
الشؤون الداخلية هنا يكتبون أن الغياب
في العمل
corpus delicti أعتقد ولكن ماذا وماذا
ما زلت أفعل أين تذهب
مشكلة ايطالما شارب السابع كلاهما ولكن الزرفي
أحد عشر
بدانا أوسع من النغمات أو فيديو الإنترنت
قادهم أيضًا إلى الاتصال بالخلفية
اتضح أنني تمكنت من ذلك
ضرب هذا هو ش شكرا لك
ثم نقل truro
إيرينا بالفعل ، كما كانت ، يمكن أن تتحرك إلى الخلف
قبض على شيء بالفعل بالفعل بطريقة أو بأخرى
جذب مسؤوليته تسقط 0
0 m a d b a city أنا من هناك عيون إيرينا
بالفعل رواسب العام لدي أطنان من Zhenya لدي مناسبات
حشود ariana وخلفية الجليد faurse أو
ماركازي وإعطائها ومازال عليها
الاتصال من السجن
ولكن بطريقة ما يطلب أن يلتقط
البيان طبيعي وما هو غريب
لا يفكر إلا في نفسه وليس بها
أي يسأل عنه حتى
من المفترض أنني لست مذنبًا بأي شيء ، خذها بعيدًا
من فضلك التطبيق
وإلا سأقتلكم جميعًا مخيف بالطبع
أولاً ، أصبحوا فجأة أصدقائي
بأي طريقة بأي طريقة
تجدني حقًا في الشارع و
ثم جدي يشبهني أكثر
أتذكر أن هؤلاء الناس كانوا على الدوام
مثل هذا من الأطفال العدوانيين
تلقى
أنهم يحبون نيكولافانو لأنهم لكنهم
اعتبر أمهاتها وأقوم بمفردهم أنا أيضًا
ثم آخر من أحبها
[موسيقى]
شحن الشارب أنا لا أذهب طحين بالرصاص آنا
وقال لي مونو حذف الوقود خلق
قطعت خلفية tante zalet ناقص areem
تم اعتماد قانون الأسرة الروسي في
1996 العد قبل 23 عاما في
قانون الأسرة الروسي 51 مقالة
حول انفصال الأبناء عن الآباء 9 مقالات
تنظيم الحرمان من حقوق الوالدين
قيود الاختيار هناك 9 من 41
المادة تسمى قسم كامل
ترك تعليم الأطفال بدون
تفاصيل رعاية الوالدين لا شيء
مدرج كوصي و
الوصاية عند تقسيمها بالفعل
انفصلوا عن والديهم ، كما كان
ترتيب تبني الأسرة الحاضنة
الاستقبال حتى سن 13 ، أي أنها لم تفعل ذلك
لم تكن هناك كلمة واحدة لمساعدة الأسرة على الإطلاق
[موسيقى]
مساهمات تاتيانا بولشاكوفا هناك أوه لا لا
thiola صور الأعمال من نفس من
أنا أبحث عن مبتكر هيدالغو وأنشئه
عرض وأنا من أعطي أنا
حيث بكت لوقت طويل جدا حتى من حقيقة ذلك
روح الله
ما الذي يشعر به الناس حقًا بالأسف تجاه شخص ما
أو تقديم المشورة إلى أين نذهب
لم أطلب واحدة جديدة ، بل واحدة من أجل الوقت
كحل
مع دمية
وما هي تاتيانا كوفال ونعم ، هذه كلها أشياء
الثانوية لمساعدة الأسرة
من الضروري أن تقبل الأسرة هذه المساعدة
الأسرة رفضا قاطعا للمساعدة
أصبح من الواضح لنا أن الطفل لديه حقيقي
هناك تهديد لحياة وصحة الجفت لنا
ثم تاتيانا في طبقة إلزامية المنزل و
كلانا حافي القدمين لنا روبن كليوما 1 أنت
الرجال أو الألبان حقل الفنادق أنا
حد tatishcheva رصاصة تاتيانا مزارات
خطأ في الحجم بالفكرة
الفيفا هو أو يمتلك حتى هؤلاء
منذ أن قامت المدارس بشريط أحذية زيد
أضواء الماس فورد نموذج الملح والماء و
السكر سيرقم موسى جليل يا سلام
محاضر تاتيانا
حسناء المسلمين مورفيم
عشرة أشخاص ويضغطون عليك فقط
الحائط هو كل شيء
هؤلاء الناس العزل ليسوا أنا لهم
أدركت أنني لا أعرف كيف
بعض قطاع الطرق هذا فقط
هذا نفسي كما يقولون نعم
affet نحن الأشخاص الذين نعمل معهم
الأطفال يحكمون على الأطفال وغرامة
يفهم ذلك
أخذ طفل هو الملاذ الأخير
تسويف الموت كما كان من قبل
يسبقه عملاق ضخم
عمل جميع مواضيع الوقاية من أجل
الزئبق تاتيانا و 0 بدون المحلة
القرود أنا هناك بهذه الكتلة ولكن فقط
أنا تاتيانا b0 الدخل من أحذية الصيف
حقل بي بليد فال للأرضيات
المحتوى الورقي في الصنادل u و rus أود
أعطى سخيف ucrania منقوشة تاهو من أجل أو
مدرسة اليكين والبعض
دورق حذاء إذا كانت مفقودة
وثيقة لمواطن من الاتحاد الروسي
لم يتم إعادة تسجيل الطفل والمعاش التقاعدي
الطفل ليس كذلك
أمي لديها تأمين صحي
انتهك حقوق الطفل
هنا أنا لا أنام فقط مع ما أنا
جاء للحصول على جواز سفر روسي من قبل
حصل على شهادة الختام
لا يوجد زواج مطلوب تأكيد هنا
تغيير اللقب ما هي الصعوبة
كان سبب عدم تمكننا من معرفة ما أنت عليه
أوكرانيا
حاولت الحصول على شيء بالمجان
حسنا قالوا 500 دولار تفعل
رجال الأعمال ماذا يمكنك أن تفعل و
ولدي هذا الدخل فقط
الشاه الصغير قرأ بقوة أهاجم
أو أحضر فيلمًا إلى هيونغ عن الطعام الذي يأكله الذهاب
la-la-la salat هذه الكرة غير متبلور
يمكنه بعد ذلك أن يرتدي صدًا عند 0 آسف لجانبنا
كما عرض علي الضفدع أن يأخذنا
طفل إلى العيادة
شرحت ذلك للعيادة
من حيث المبدأ ، لا داعي ، لدي إجابة
الرسمية
من العيادة تقول shpak بدون
إطالة التشخيص الرئيسي و
تحديد الإعاقة غير ممكن
أخذت كل الزميلة الحامضة
أن التشخيص خاطئ
من الضروري
اعطى طبيب الروماتيزم معها
الطفل وصلاحيته ، لكنني فهمت ذلك
إذا حصلت عليه الآن
إعاقة لأمراض الروماتيزم سيتم تسريحه
علاج خلل التنسج الضام
والتهاب المفاصل الروماتويدي أنت هنا جيدًا نوعًا ما
معاملة مختلفة تمامًا
مناعة وهناك مثبطات مناعة
اتصل بطبيب القط بك
دعنا نقول قبل ذلك كان هناك ملاحظة جيدة هذا
لا يحل المشكلة كان من الضروري القيادة
ووزارة الصحة والمراسلات كلها أو الأهم
كنت بحاجة لطفل لقيادة العرض 2015
سنوات بانتظام
إدارة المدرسة
تطبق على سلطات ومؤسسات النظام
المنع مع طلب التأثير على الأم
والتأكد من أن الطفل يحصل على كامل
تعليم عام
مرات الصيد وآمل أن لا يكون المخرج
غير قادر على تقديم الخدمات المنزلية
التعلم
لأنه يبدو أن الطفل ليس لديه أجهزة كمبيوتر
كان في هذا المجد الصريح العصي
والله اعلم ان الطفل عنده حاسوب
يقترب
كنت أسير مثل الغبار ، نقلت الطفل إلى الأسرة
أشكال التعليم هناك أتت إلي هنا
البريد من وزارة التربية والتعليم
خطاب يفيد باستلام إخطار
حول اختيار الوالدين القانوني
ممثل التعليم
شكل الأسرة
قبل عام الطفل هذا في المنزل
لم يكن لدي تدريب ولا شكاوى
المعلمين لم يذهبوا إلى منازلهم وكانوا مضطرين لذلك
يمشون لكنهم لم يمشوا معي كل يوم
تم نقل الطفل إلى المدرسة بين ذراعي الأم
محادثة شفوية مع مدير المدرسة
حذرت من أنها ستذهب للعيش في الغابة و
تلتقط الطفل تعطي ما تذهب
مطبات الغابات آسف جيدا لا معنى لذلك
يبدو الأمر كما في هذه العبارة أنا آكل بعضًا
لم يكن على المحك وهم بالفعل من غير المرجح أني
أريد أن أهرب إلى الغابة لأعيش مع ضلع بقرة
سوف يتسلق بهذه الطريقة بناءً على
سحب الأدلة التي تم جمعها في القضية
يعتقد أن اللامبالاة والسلوك
المتهمين فيما يتعلق الحيوية
جانب من جوانب حياة الطفل
مجرد عصر الطفل مع الأم
هو للسديم
محامي خطير اقتربت من الثمن
محضر المحكمة الثقيلة عندما بالفعل
حصلت على أمر إعدام
اقرأ أمر الإعدام
أنني مدين بالفعل بنفقة هناك ومن أجلها
الجو
حسنًا ، كأنني جمعت شجاعتي
أفكار قبل الأكل أنا تشارما روبن هود و
العرافة على الحليب
آل فاليدا وليس تاتيانا الفارو
الفيلم المفضل للنهائي 1 ahaul the
مجانا كيف كسر و 5 أنا فيمو تو
ثلاث طبقات من راديو ألين كار k جورب الشهير
[موسيقى]
من تاريخ قرار المحكمة في
تقييد حقوق الوالدين من ذلك
في اللحظة التي تم فيها أخذ طفلهم بعيدًا
فحص يقرأ غيرتها
سلوك غير قانوني
يقول بيان النهر أنه طفل
وصلتهم درجة حرارة 3 جيسيكا
عاد من العمل مع طفل مصاب بالحرارة
لم يتم فحص الطفل لم يولد
تشخيص الطفل لم يشف
[موسيقى]
ألفا له هذه هم هذه الكرة
طاولة له وليمة عرض برول الحامل
دودي العتيق زرعنا وعد
وموقع مومياء العجول الخلفية
تمرر هذا الدرس حول هذه الحصة بين
نماذج منازل الأخيرات
هل كتبوا دلما دوريس طويلا
دكتور موسى الأسهل قد يكون أفضل
أفعل ذلك يأتي في بداية المعركة
جاميا
الفا تاتوم هذا مينجو من الخرز الصلب
نرى النموذج 1 m s وسأفحص bois
أسعد أنت فقط من وأنا هنا تاتا أذهب
انتهى أعطى ثم أعطت سارة
[موسيقى]
نيكولاس ماي لوف كافيه أنمي هاوس
تقييم مع أوراق الملحق قبل حلول الظلام
ضيقة لها ثريا جمعت قابلة
التفاصيل مهد طائر بندقية الحبار
مصارعه فورد كابري وداولات في اذنك.
حصار
[موسيقى]
نعتقد أنه كان لديه كل شيء هناك
سوف تكون قادرة على القيام بذلك
سيتركك ستوبين وهذا فقط
الفتاة لا تفكر بنفس الطريقة بالنسبة له
انها تفكيك ليس هناك ليس من الواضح أين
هل كان أي نيوت يشرب الخمر و
أخذناهم من هناك ، لكنهم لم يفعلوا
رأى الحجارة كانت موجودة وماذا كانت
فهمت ذلك
والضباب أفضل هنا وربما نكون هناك
مع أمي
أي خمسة لدينا هذا كل شيء
حسنًا ، وهنا كانوا يأملون في هذا الأخير
على ما يبدو وبعد ذلك أدركوا أن ما
وألقى أمي
ثم سلطة المعلم هذه السيرة الذاتية كارينا
بسط لك طبقة عدن أو مباشرة
دوروثي في ​​وجهي
كارينا مرضت تكتب لي متوحشة
لم أرها لم أرها عندما تكتب
أبلغ عن حالة الذروة وأين توجد الشرطة
أن لديك عائلة هناك كل شيء مربك للغاية
ضعيف
وإلا فهو من خشب البتولا في أعلى 5 لك
بينها موديلات عموم لديها على الإطلاق
خلايا نحل نعم وسقوط قذائف هاون وأنا كذلك
بكت وكارينا بكت أيضا عندما
اتصلت بهم كوليا وأنت تعرف هذا
كانت هناك مدارس وسيؤخذ على الفور الأيدي ولا شيء
لا يزال لا يمكنك البحث وهذا كل شيء
سوف يأخذونها على أي حال ، أقول إذا كان الأمر على ما يرام ، حسنًا
أود أن أقول دعنا نذهب لمجرد
لقد كانوا معًا فتيات باتيرين بحاجة إلى ذلك
عدد البيزيتا المراد مراجعتها بشرط
نحن مجموعة إدارية ، هل هذا يعني
قرر ما هو مطلوب
ضع الأطفال في مؤسسة أنت شيتا دي
المدن التي سكولكوفو ليست أنفا
سوف يرضي الاتصال مع الحياة الصعبة
المواقف التي يكون فيها المال غير كافٍ جدًا
ذات مغزى سلبي جدا أنيق
الكتان هذا بالنسبة لك أعتقد ذلك
التعليق على الوضع ، بما في ذلك
المتخصصين في صالة للألعاب الرياضية لأنه كان
الدهون بين الأقسام أي
شرع في الخروج من الأسرة ل
الامتحانات للحصول على توضيحات للبقاء بدون
الفتاة ، أي أنها لم تكن لفترة طويلة
يزور صفراء حتى كم
اسأل جيدا
مؤسسة تعليمية كافية
اضطررت لشراء ربما الفتيات
بياضات
إذا اعتقدوا أنهم لم يكونوا كافيين
عقدة أغطية السرير
بدلا من إبعادهم عن الأسرة
يفترض الآن استدار المعلم
مربي اجتماعي إلى اجتماعي
معلم
الجذر وليس اتصال جيد جدا مع
زوج الأم ، ربما يكون على اتصال
ستصبح شاشة معلم اجتماعي
يبدو
بدأ يسأل عن الفصل المناسب أو أكثر
قالت شيئًا أننا لا ندفع شيئًا
لن يكون وعلى هذه الخلفية المعلم الذي هو
بدأت عائلتنا تتعامل بشكل سيء
رينين كارينا
مرضت وتقيأت في الدرس المعلم
جعلها الركود تأخذ قطعة قماش وأكثر من ذلك
وضع الفصل الراديو بعيدًا بنفسي
كان الطفل مريضا ، ذهبت إليها
المسموح والمعلم من حيث
هنا
بعض الوثائق فعلت كل شيء
المعلم المناسب للغاية على الإطلاق
لم يكن الهدف إزالة كارينا من الفصل
لا يوجد فأر يمكن العثور عليه حتى لنكون صادقين
صدمنا أنفسنا عندما صدمنا الفتاة
نخضع الجلد لسلطة الوصاية و
الوصاية قبل الاوراق وانفسنا
دعنا لا نقلق
المدرسة هي مثل الجزء الذي ليس جيلي
قبل النوم من قبل أنظمة ما يسمى
التعاون بين الوكالات
يتحول إلى مثل هذا القمعي
الجهاز ، أي غير مرفوض
الوالد يتلقى إشارة نعم و
علاوة على ذلك ، كما يقولون ، ها نحن هنا
حدثت حالات فيلم مؤخرًا
مرتبط بأحد النشطاء المشهورين
معنا وحقوق أمين المظالم
الحقوق وأمناء المظالم
طفل ردا على سؤال حول
كيف يمكن للمرء أن يتفاعل مع الإدانة
مجهول في الواقع نعم قالوا جيدًا
لا يمكن أن تفشل الخدمات في الاستجابة
حمية ديما بيرم
صالون الكبار lidami lyudmila yuldasheva هو
وأي شخص سيراتو الغول لا يزال حتى لثلاثة
طبقة
هناك و pugallino نفس أنبوب كيو تودو
سعيد لدي هؤلاء وغزال كندا ماري
ماذا كانت المكالمة من cdn تريد
تحقق من ظروف معيشتي بشكل عام
لم أدع زيارة المخبوزات ، ولم أنشر ، ولم أفعل
دع cdm
حسنًا ، ليس بشكل عام ، يمكنك القول
قمع عائلتي ، لكن كل شيء حدث
على أساس إدانة كاذبة ، بشكل عام ، لا
لم تجد شيئًا أفضل من جذبها لشيء ما
أن أطفالي كانوا بصحة جيدة في الثامن عشر
أحد قاصري
لم يقم الأطفال بزيارة العيادة وبعد ذلك بالفعل
كان هناك محادثة بين رئيس العيادة
قالت إنها كانت تحت ضغط من أعلى
وزارة الصحة
حتى يتم وضع عائلتي بأي شكل من الأشكال
المحاسبة لمجموعة مخاطر لأي شيء لا
خذها لعدم مرور الوقت
الفحوصات الجسدية بشكل عام ، كان الهدف هو الأكثر
الشيء الرئيسي هو أن أضع عائلتي اللعنة
خنزير وعن كنز ونثر بطانية على
قطع حسابي على شركة آه آه آه
جوائز ملح ليودميلا
efremkina bisu ghoul الآية demoman zuma
قيم التجانب هي نعم ومع
[موسيقى]
و ahaul nikolay fimo do and blackie
كانت تعيش في الشريحة وخدمة الصلاة بعد ذلك وهناك
لديك الآن كتلة وأذى أعتقد ذلك أنا
عادة ما تكون نظريات السموم amalia وألواح
dominguez 5 يقود خط ديدا
عشنا بدون أم ، سننجح بدونها
الجلوس هنا على توفير الأطفال دائمًا
كانت ممتلئة
أنا أفعل الإعلانات الخارجية
أنا أدرس مع رفيق أثناء الملاحظة
من الطبيب إلى الشمس سأستعير لك بالفعل
نادى نيكولاي سوبيرو من بستوني إليه
وطُرحت أسئلة لن آخذها
أنت لا تتخيلهم ، لقد فوجئت بالكتابة والكتابة والكتابة
نكتب أنها تعني لا أنت لا أحد ولكن
يتصلون به ولا أعرف على الهاتف
تسمى العروض لقد حصلت على موعد
إلى رأس الوصاية على السفينة وقد أخبرتني بالفعل
ثم يقول لماذا يجب أن تعطى
تبرع مجانا
لقد صدمت من هذه المباشرة
مثل المتجر الذي جئت لأكون من بعدهم
لماذا لا يكون مجانيًا أبدًا ثم lobo
نيكولاس مثل هذه الوعود لكابل الخلافة
فيبي خيط ذهب يو وللأفلام مش لي
كان مريضا احضر خلافتك
أي معلومات عن
دعونا ندع نيكولاي ستانيسلاف يذهب إلى فينيتسا من
بطريقة ما منعهم من
قبول طلب عدم تقديم المساعدة
أو على حساب بعض الأوصياء الآخرين
هؤلاء الفتيات لم يكن لدينا دورة
الفحوصات
قانونيا ، لدينا نيكولاي فينيتسكي
لم يكن ستيفانوفيتش وصي
عداء ببطء لا يعطى الوالدان جدا
إعادة النموذج الذي جاء به الأطفال الذين درسوا
التماسًا للمحكمة بالحرمان
أمهات هؤلاء الفتيات من حقوق اللغة الإنجليزية
تم اتخاذ قرار المحكمة الآن
ما هو الوقت فقط في إجابتنا
لمقدم طلب Venevsky كلمات رائعة
ما الذي كان عليه أن يتكاثر حول ما كان عليه
لديه بعض المؤشرات
حق الأولوية في التأسيس
الوصاية
لم يكن هناك سبب للانفصال و
تحطيم هذه الأسرة من الأسئلة رجلاً رجلًا
لماذا تم ذلك
الأسرة ليست على الإطلاق عائلة هامشية
يعمل الأب الطبيعي تمامًا بنفس الطريقة
اليوم الذي أصلحوه فيه
وثقت حقيقة أن الأم
فتاة صغيرة تعيش منذ أكثر من عام
ممثلي الوصي و
الوصاية من قبل الإنسان فقط
كان يجب أن يصل إلى نيكولاي
تعال إلى الأسرة لإضفاء الطابع الرسمي
الحضانة المؤقتة هي وفقا ل
القسم 12 قانون الوصاية الفيدرالي
والوصاية كانت مطلوبة لهذا الغرض
فقط جواز سفر نيكولاس الثاني
فحص
الظروف المعيشية ، أي الشقق
تعيش الفتاة منذ سنوات عديدة
وما شابه ذلك من حالة مماثلة
على سبيل المثال ، في نفس المنزل الصغير
تصادم قبل عام عندما كنا
سنوات حاولت بالفعل إعادة الأطفال
الصفحة الرئيسية
هؤلاء هم نفس الفنانين بالضبط سيدتي
موظفي السفينة فالكوفا سيدتي
وزارات التنمية الاجتماعية
إقليم بيرم تاس الإقليمية
الإدارة رقم أربعة لماذا تومسك
منطقة
فيكتوريا احذية المحدد ميدان لدينا من
صالة جنتي من الزي الرسمي للمعاقين والفطائر و
وكذلك لفيبي من هناك قتلت الصورة 2
هل هذا انت مرح
ستكون المحاور بعيدة عن الحقول التي يقودها الآيات
افلام المعجبين تفعل u oli حتى يتم اخماد هذا اللغز و
هم منزل آسيوي
صناديق Annette تدفع إنها Duckworth yo
سهل هذا الفيلم
بالله والروح والمزيد من الرحلات مجانا
صور طلاء الرأس فوق ميداليات الكعب ليست قوية
تحترق مثل سطح جيدا
تبين أنها مقطوعة هنا ولكن هذا كل شيء
النصف الصغير هو المستشفى بالطبع
أحصى الوالدان أن الطائر يستحق جيدًا
يمكنهم التعامل مع أنفسهم
التواريخ الخاطئة قد تكون بسببهم
بدأت من هذا القبيل
ليس لدينا إمدادات المياه
منزل لا يعمل رقاقة المياه
نحن نتسامح مع المثليين حول المرحاض
قالوا أيضًا إن المسافة كانت 50 مترًا وفي المنزل
يقع لي شيء في نفس اليوم
وصلوا عندما كانوا في المستشفى حيث و
يقلى مأخوذ يقول إذا لم تفعل
كتابة بيان لمدة ستة أشهر هذا الأخدود
محدودة في الحقوق جيدا ، سنأخذ الأطفال
تلقائيا
الحلول تأتي على الفور مع دعوى قضائية وجميعهم
الذين لا يسلب كل منهم شيئًا في حياته
ثم بدأت الصدمة في لقاء مع الأطفال
تحتاج إلى إحضار شهادة التجارة ، وهذا هو
تقدموا كل شهر و
في كل مرة يكون لديهم كائن هي فقط
طالبت السخرية بصراحة هناك
حزمة كاملة من هذه الوثائق
من طبيب امراض جلدية وطبيب نفساني
الاهتمام بنقل الأطفال من
العائلات الأصلية
هذه هي قطع api العائلية وفي هذا
كل الممثلين مهتمون بالحركة
نصيب الفرد من التمويل في كل مكان
إذا كان الطفل في
مستشفى أي سوف تتلقى المستشفيات من
يجب فهم حالات الوسائل
من أين تحصل على هذه الأموال؟
تمتلئ منه ليتم الوفاء به
العناصر الواجب دفعها
الآباء الذين أخذنا الطفل منهم
نصل إلى الجوهر هناك بالفعل دفعة واحدة و
على الزجاج ، أشغل مواقف القاضي فجأة
عند المطالبة بعيدًا عن الاستعادة في
حقوق الوالدين فجأة
اتضح أن العملاق كان في هذا لفترة طويلة
100 ألف روبل ليسوا على الفور ، كما كان
سرق مزرعة الدولة قطعة من الورق جاء ماشا وهم
كان راتبي هناك 12-13 ألف
Troevich 50 في المئة نجحنا
إعادة هؤلاء الأطفال إلى الأسرة
ماذا نعتقد حول ما يواجهونه
الناس الذين لا يعرفون عنا
وليس هناك 10 أو 50 حالة من هذا القبيل ، ولا يوجد جدول
وأكثر من ذلك بكثير أنا أول من لصق HD بواسطة
ميدان حار لمنحهم العجاف
أشعر وكأنني شعرت بالفعل عندما
أنا أعاني من الاكتئاب منذ أكثر من عام
كان الاكتئاب
عندما أعرف أطفالي أحد التفاصيل
على استعداد للموت 2 في خطاب الاكتئاب
صفحة كاملة كتبها أمي أحبك
أنا أحب أنني مستعد حتى للموت وأنك
دائما تكون أمي akiyuki تقتل
هذه الروح العليا
لقد كتب الكثير
Plakida Tatyana لكنهم يستهدفونني على طول الطريق
انتظري نصيبي من ليالينا كيف
إعطاء اللعنة u hero5 أفراد مجال التبت
المسار إلى قدم نموذج فندق كيليا جدا
يقال أن هذا أعتقد أنهم كسروا الصين باتي
بليان
ث لا في يا لكنك أيها الناس الجديد
جاء اليوم الثاني بعد ولادتها
لي فالكوفا بدون طبيب نفساني بدون
جئت للتو وتقول لا تتخلى عن زوج
شقة لا لاحتواء شيء
كطفل حيث تعيش ليس لديك مكان تعيش فيه
من أن أرفض أقول أبكي كذب أبكي
هذا وكذلك لا ، لا أريد أن أرفض هيا
لن تستسلم ثم بعد ذلك
العام يقول وقع هنا
ما يبدو لي عندما كانت بوابة ثلاثة أيام
طوال العام لا يزال يؤلمني
وقعت التوت أوراق اليرقات
يأتي شخص ما هناك
يأخذ الطاقم الطبي الطفل بعيدًا عني
ثم أدركت أنني أخذوني بعيدًا
الطفل بعد أن أدركت بالفعل أنني
أخذت الطفل ثم أنا عندما فالكوفا
مع من جاءني بيتكو هنا
قيل لي أنني سأتخذ خطوة أخرى فقط
قلت لينا التقى الأطفال مرة أخرى
لقد جاؤوا إلي ، ثم أرهبوني ، حسنًا ، بعد ذلك
لا يمكنني الذهاب معك و
مسكين
أحمق الأرجواني قلت اذهب إلى مكتب المدعي العام
اكتب بيانا عن الطفل
للعودة ذهبت المنعطفات
اتضح أنها سارت وقالت
وكل ما كتبته بيان موقع
كل المشاكل الهائلة التي تقدمها الخدمات الاجتماعية
اسم السفينة كل الساعات si من الجثث بالطبع
الوصاية والوصاية أولا
لا يحملون أي منها
المسؤولية ولم يتم توفيرها ل
غير شرعي
نقل الأطفال من العائلات دون قيد أو شرط
يجب إدخالها حتى
المسؤولية الجنائية بسبب
في بعض الحالات هم فقط صارخون
على سبيل المثال ، في نفس الحالة لدي نيكولاس
وقف شعري عند نهايته عندما قرأته
خاتمة اخصائية نفسية احدى الفتيات
عانى من صدمة نفسية رهيبة
كان لديها لأنه كان بالفعل كسر و
والنتائج المضافة
البحث النفسي والويبرنوم
في وقت الفحص
حالة عصبية نفسية من الويبرنوم
سيئة نوعا ما
تم تشخيصه بضعف التكيف
زيادة القدرة على التكيف مع الظروف الجديدة
القلق العدوان الخفي الشعور
الشك والخوف من اللحظة
الوضع بالنسبة لكارين ليس تمامًا
مفهومة لذلك ثق بها
ستبدأ عائلة كارين المحيطة في تكوين أسرة
التي عاشت قبل التوبة
يسلب أكبر حجم
توج دلالة اختيارية للبابا
تولى نيكولاس شقيقة بلوتو و
الجدة تماراك أمي تجربة المشاعر
قريبة من الإهمال العاطفي ل
الحفاظ على الصحة العقلية
تقليل القلق و
يجب أن تؤخذ في الاعتبار
طفل
[موسيقى]
الخوف من الحياة لاسو يظهر لك طبقة العقل
لتكون قليلا مع حمل ما يصل حرب الضغط
فيلم وخز أودع بالفعل g5 ball ghoul
الدافع الرئيسي هو بالطبع هذا
نصيب الفرد من التمويل ، أي الكل للجميع
اهتمامات هذا الطفل لزيارتها
لهم في النهاية من المثير للاهتمام أنه دخل فيها
أسرة حاضنة نسمع عنها كثيرًا
حقيقة أن الأوصياء هم هؤلاء في كثير من الأحيان
يتقاضون رواتبهم ما يسمى الأسوار
مسؤولي الوصاية و
ليس لدينا دليل على وصاية
لأنها تحتاج إلى التشغيل
تنمية الطفل لتسيير ما أستطيع
فقط الأشخاص المصرح لهم بذلك
استبدال الألم كايلي نيكولايفا تمارا
نافورة الميزانية dimwitted لذلك أنت أنت
أعتقد أن هذا هو النموذج العلوي والقشر سهل
ابيل موساتوف والبرد ونيكولاي عنه
تكون عربة الهريس أو الركبة أ
سم الصخور الحمراء وأنا أيضا أي كاتب روبيو
وله أولاً بصوت ساذج على ورقة الشجر
على مخدر ريو والعجول ثيوفيلوس اللحام نفسه
روح kulibin في نهاية العملة أم أنك جندي
سقط التفتا لويس يو غابا اسم ترودات
حذاء الاصالة يخبئ بعيدا
[موسيقى]
أريد أن أذهب إلى المنزل وأعرض جيما نيكولاي
ليحل محله العنان لك بينما أولغا بهم
عاش الشتاء في فصل الشتاء عاليا وديف
الممسوح لروث دالتون سيكون أقل
[موسيقى]
لنا كوليا لذكر ناتاليا أدناه
ضمير نوفغورود يوفا أتيت أنا
قيدوا ارتفاعًا لمدة عام لديّ كليو ميتال
أو سحق الشراب
ألمح لصائق لاستبدال lyulya
hamidullin canele نسف حجة وزارة الدفاع
حتى الساعة 10 مساءً
الحماية من الوصاية وصلت ثم هناك الناس
15 يقف على حق مثل هذا
لقد جئنا وكأننا بحاجة إلى قرط
خذ اليورو إلى المستشفى لفحص سبب وجوده
ليس لديك لعبة مسجلة في أي مكان
رفع بطريقة ما وسنقدم الشهر
لقد ذهبت بالفعل إلى المتجر و 39 عيادة خارجية
اليورو ما هو الأمر بشكل عام نحن الآن
طفل والتقاط الحجارة صالة الذباب
ارتفاع شاهق مثل الفتاة تطوي يدي
كيف كسرت ولكنني بطبيعة الحال
هرعت إلى الطفل وقالت إنها لم يكن لي بأي حال من الأحوال
خدشت يدي بالكامل ، ثم بعد ذلك
أدرت عربة الأطفال فارغة
زاوية المصعد
حسنًا ، إذا كنت في أي حالة هنا
ودُفنت الابنة ولم يؤخذ الطفل من أي شيء
لم يخبروا أي مستشفى هناك ما أنا
لم أقل شيئًا على الإطلاق
تنفجر في البكاء
كنت ماكسي مستقيم بشكل رهيب
[موسيقى]
آل mods إنها أخف من لي للحظة tov
قتلت أنا أحب الطعام وهذه المروحة تؤلمني
الحيوية خاصة
أوليا الغيتار kallus الأعمال الاحتلالات كنت
في المدرسة ، كان أندرو مريضًا وأنا
وصية الحب الحقيقي الذي يثيره
اعتقدت أنه ليس لدي أي شيء من هذا القبيل حتى الآن
فعلت لاصطحابي ، آتي و
في الكوميديا ​​، والدي جبان ، أتذكر هناك تحت و
كيف كان يضرب والدته فقط على ظهره
ضربها بحبة ولم تتعرف عليه
فأنت في الأساس عم صغير سمين
جلست للتو وبدأت في قول شيء من هذا القبيل
تعال إلي المخرج هو نفسه
البداية لأنه ليس مثل جدتك
سيكون النوم السيئ سيكون أفضل
جون يهدد بأننا إذا لم نوقع
المستندات ، ثم سنغادر هنا حيث نحن في المنزل
شعرت بالخوف من التوقيع على كل الوثيقة
أتيت هنا حتى تكون كلابًا إلى الأبد
ركض إلى الجدة قال هنا
جاء أبي هنا كل هؤلاء الجيران
قفز خارج دائرة أقصر من الأطفال يريد
اصطحبهم إلى تامبوف إلى منطقة تامبوف
والجيران لم يعطوا طن ، اذهبوا إلى الأطفال
سخر وابنتك ضربته أنا محشوة
حتى تتعرف على الوجه الذي عيناها
على الإطلاق لم يكونوا جزءًا من إجمالي منتفخ
كان هناك جار هنا فتاة لم يفعلها
حصل هنا في هذا المكان لأنه لم يحصل
ركل
لوى شعره حول ذراعه وسحب و
منزل الذئب
هرب الجميع هناك والجميع عرف الفضيحة
كان فظيعا جاء للعمل
القصر
أعطى الأحذية ل kbs و الشكل كاسيو
أعطها أو حصلت على كوليا سيرجي
المادة 117 ط
سخان نقول وادي الأسطورة خطوة بخطوة
للقيام بذلك الكثير من البرامج الضارة صوفيا
استجابت المياه لذلك بعناية
هذا هو الألم الذي تسببه الوصاية بهذه الطريقة
من معنا جاء الناس من كل مكان
شخص ما يرسل المال الأشياء ولكن كثيرا من
ما هو كل هذا الأثاث
كل شيء قدمه لنا الناس أتى كل شيء غير مرغوب فيه
تم طرحه من قبل المحيط اللعين لنفسه هنا
hoot albeto mod alibi واجب
الرقص من على متن الطائرة سيرجي كود الأصدقاء
العمل ثم لا الحشيش مرحبا أنا
الجدة سريوزا بارانوفا
ها هم مرحبا اقول لكم كيف حاله هناك
كل شيء على ما يرام كل شيء على ما يرام
وبعد ذلك سننا هل تعلم جاهز
ستكون محكمة لأي سبب هو أنا
مجموعة حول ما يريدون السنة
اختيار الآباء بالتبني سكان موسكو
Serezhenka تأتي هنا أرجواني وتأتي في الشتاء
اسرع دميتي
قطتي الصغيرة
لم أكن لأراه قط
مثل حمل من روسيا لوقف الهبوط
فريق teya motherfly عندما أعيش
أنيا في يد أن بوني النظام الغذائي لهم بالفعل
وسأغادر سكان موسكو سيرجي للنظر فيها
ماذا تريدني
ألبينا الذئب قيم ممسحة المصباح أودي
هذه صور عندما نلتقط بجدية ملف
تم نشر هذه الصورة على
إقامة لجولة الأيتام
لدينا قانون يقول
أن للطفل الحق في الأقارب
اتصالات وبالطبع كان الأمر سهلاً بالنسبة لي
ولكن كان الوضع رائعًا
على أي أساس يتأثر الجهاز
الوصاية تعطي الاستنتاج أن الطفل
جولة اليتيم
وكان أسوأ ما في الأمر أنه إذا
سيكون
تم استيفاء الادعاء من حق الطفل
فقد أقاربهم إلى الأبد
لن يعرفوا أبدًا
حيث يكون الطفل مع من هم
قد لا يعرفون حتى
سواء كان على قيد الحياة أم لا ، اتضح أنها كانت هنا
انتهك هنا هو في هذه المحكمة الحق على الفور
ثلاثة أطفال
لا أحد يهتم ، نعم أصعد
دوران
أنا الآن لكل طفل من بئري
كما يقولون ، سأقطع حلقي
[موسيقى]
لقد فقد كل شيء ، الأب والأم
قيل وخسر الاسم ولن يعرفه
ماذا او ما
وأن لديه أقارب ولكن
تقديم شخص ما للطفل على الفور
نوع من القلب تشعر به كثيرًا بالنسبة لي
سيكون سيئا
لا يزال هذا البكاء وباستمرار
أنا أبكي طوال الوقت
[موسيقى]
إلى الكسر وأعطيت أكثر من الفيلم ، كما اعتقدوا
مدح طبقة لميزانيتك حصة اندفاعة
بيتا
على الأقل على شاشة التلفاز الحولة سحب الكتلة
فيدور ريد ينكر الجدة في
على أساس أنها لم تفعل ذلك
تتواءم مع تربية الحفيد الأكبر
لم يكن هناك أيضا
والوصاية أوضحت ذلك من خلال حقيقة أن أولاً ،
الطفل لديه نزاع مع
وجد الأقران أن أحد
قال المراهقون في حضور أندريوشا
ماتت أمك الصغيرة لذلك أنت بحاجة إليها
سبب آخر
من المفترض أن تربية أندريوشا سيئة
كان بيان ميتروفانوفا إيلينا
جيناديفنا
أن الطفل يتشرد
التشرد أكدت في المحكمة عنها
محضر ضباط الشرطة الذين
محتجز
مراهق يبلغ من العمر 15 عام 1015 بدون
مرافقة الكبار إلى الشارع
لعبت في ملعب كرة القدم كمستشارين
عاد إلى المنزل في الصيف تم نقله إلى المنزل و
وعندما ترك الوقت قبل ذلك كان هناك
10 15 بل لسؤال القاضي وفي ماذا
كان تشرد ميتروفانوف
مما يجعل العيون مندهشة للغاية
سأصبح مثل محكمة محترمة ، لأنه متى
تم اعتقاله
احصل على اللون الأزرق في الشارع الذي هو البرازيل
هذا يعني أن يتجول هنا مثل هذا المنطق و
هذا المستوى من المعرفة مع الفلسفية
انحياز، نزعة
الرئيس يشرب جميع الديار و
إقليمي لكننا فزنا بكل الملاعب باختصار
لم يهدأ ميتروفانا
لقد استأنفت ضد تلك المحاكم الثلاث ، نعم ، يبدو لي
لم تستطع تخيل ماذا
ثم ردتها جدتي معي
اشتباه في رغبتها في بيع القرط
بالطبع لا أستطيع أنا متى
دعا لتثبيت il nitsa ومتى
اكتشفت أننا ربحنا المحكمة
لن يعمل شيء لها هنا وها هي
أسقطت تلك العبارة
كيف يمكنني سحب نقود تحتها؟
سيعود
أين فهمت
شيء سيء يحدث في الحجز
لدينا قانون
انتهاك متكرر لحقوق الأطفال
الجثث يشرب تأتي مجرم
المسؤولية في هذا الأمر
فوجئ بمنصب مكتب المدعي العام
الحضرية والإقليمية
في هذا الصدد ، لدينا مرارا وتكرارا
أبلغت عن الانتهاكات لرئيس السلطات
الوصاية وفي مكتب المدعي العام في المدينة
الادارة
لكن هنا أعتقد أنه لا يعمل
الموارد الإدارية وما يسمى ب
لا ينبغي تكريم زيه
هيا بعد عامين رأس الجسد
الوصاية
لم تجلب لها أي عقوبة
يمثل كذلك سلطاتنا
كان من غير السار أن نسمع
تبدأ في حماية الفقراء
الفقير
ومعنا من السطر السابع تحت الخط
يقولون لي الفقر ولكن الألجيني
نحن نحترمك كثيرًا كشخص جيد
هامشي أيضا
من الذي تأخذه ليحمي لي من أي وقت مضى
لأن الوحدة هي أولئك الأشخاص الذين
تنتهك الحقوق
الصورة ليست هامشية والوحدة موجودة بالفعل
هناك كل القوانين هناك وضع
الرئيس قبل إنقاذ الأسرة لخلق
آليات جميع المراسيم
لا شيء يعمل ، المادة 70
تأمر الحرمان من أجل الأسرة فقط
حقوق الوالدين
اكتب مباشرة في هذه المقالة بسيطة
كلمات مثل النظر من قبل المحاكم والمطالبات
على الحرمان من حقوق الوالدين و
يُسمح باتخاذ قرارات بشأن هذا الدافع
فقط عند تقديم تقرير إلى المحكمة بتاريخ
فرد مكتمل
العمل الوقائي لتقديمه
مساعدة التعافي الأسري
علاقة الوالدين والطفل الخلاص
العائلات
مصنع دار الأيتام الكامل 100 يتيم في اليوم
سوف يقف
لأنهم لا يستطيعون
النظر في الحرمان من حقوق الوالدين
حتى الوصاية أو cdn أو استئناف المحكمة
في الدفاع كان يعمل كعائلة ومتى
يبدأ الضمان الاجتماعي في العمل هنا كثيرًا
اتضح أنه لم يعد لا رجوع فيه
عملية الآن لا توجد حالات
ميؤوس منه الذي يجادل صغيرة ولكن لا يزال
في كثير من الأحيان أقل بكثير مما كانت عليه عندما
فقط هذا المصنع
[موسيقى]
هل هو